Hey youtubers it's Charlie and recently there
were loads of Cybermen filming at St Paul's
cathedral for the series 8 finale so in honor
of that I wanted to do a video for my Top
10 Cybermen episodes. Comic Con is next week
and even though Doctor Who isn't going I'm
still going to do a Doctor Who themed giveaway.
I'll explain that at the end of this video.
Hello new people, if you're just finding me
for the first time I do Doctor Who videos
every week. Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I've got a bunch of fun stuff planned for
when the new episodes start.
So just to explain the Cybermen at St Paul's
cathedral. The rumor is that the scene they
were filming was an homage to a scene from
The Season 6 episode The Invasion. That's
Classic Who Season 6, it was a Second Doctor
episode.
The episode is notable because it was the
last big Cybermen story until the 1975 episode
Revenge of The Cybermen. It featured the classic
Mondas design. I also think this was the first
television episode to feature St Paul's Cathedral
on screen. The only other reference I could
find to it being in an episode was in archival
footage during the series 5 finale The Big
Bang.
The scene itself looks like a big callback
plus there was a Mondas Cybermen head seen
on set.
I wonder if that means Steven Moffat is going
to retire the Cybermen for the remainder of
his tenure? Either way let's talk about the
Top 10 Cybermen episodes.
Number 10 - Tomb of The Cybermen
This was their first appearance. The Second
Doctor arrives on the planet Telos with an
archeological crew that tries to revive them.
The Doctor of course defeated them and resealed
the tomb.
It set up the whole idea of cybermats, the
little computer mice looking devices and the
cyber controller, the one that controls all
cybermen.
I have a feeling if this episode were made
today a cybermat would be seen zooming off
into the distance after the TARDIS left just
as a teaser that they would return at some
point. You can thank Marvel Movie culture
for making those final credit scenes such
a huge deal today. Even though Soap Operas
on tv have been doing that kind of thing for
a long time.
This episode was also notable because it's
the oldest surviving Second Doctor episode.
Even though this original design looks a lot
different from the future Mondas cybermen,
they are also consider Cybermen and part of
the Cyber Empire which included all pre-Cybus
versions of the characters.
I don't really consider the Cybus Industries
Cybermen as part of this group. But it gets
a little confusing because during the 2005
reboot the 11th Doctor kept running into the
Cyber Legion Fleet in space. But they were
based on the Cybus designs. So their space
fleet should technically be different from
the Mondas Cyber Fleet.
Number 9 - The Invasion
This was that last Cybermen episode before
the big break. It's them Invading current
day London and marching around in the streets
like awful space tourists before UNIT and
The Doctor took care of them.
There's a lot of interesting non-cybermen
stuff about this episode. From a production
standpoint they were using the episode as
a test for the new format of the show. Instead
of the way you see an hour long episode broken
into acts. The old Doctor who episodes were
physically separated into story arcs. It would
be like airing a Series 8 episode and cutting
it up into all the different acts and posting
those as separate episodes inside a single
story.
It's a little weird, but web series today
still do stuff like that.
It was also intended as a sort of a follow
up to Web of Fear which was from season 5,
the year before Invasion. That was another
Invasion modern day story that also involved
UNIT and the Great Intelligence.
So be on the lookout for Great Intelligence
Easter Eggs in the Series 8 finale. That's
not airing till November or December, they
haven't said if they'll be any off weeks in
series 8. It's totally possible they could
just air all 12 episodes back to back and
then take a few weeks off before the christmas
special.
Number 8 - The Five Doctors
This is like porn for classic Cybermen fans.
It featured three different cyber controllers,
even though two of them ate it pretty fast.
The episode itself is a little silly, but
that was kind of the point. And art always
gets re-interpreted so people who watched
this when it first aired probably feel different.
It's so much fun though, the modern series
hasn't really shown off a lot of Gallifrey
the way the classic series did. Although I
know a lot of you think that the TARDIS was
traveling into the Pocket Universe where Gallifrey
is hidden in the series 8 trailer.
I'll totally save that for another video just
because we could spend all day talking about
it.
More Cybermen, moving on to Number 7 - Earthshock
This was another episode that brought them
back from a long hiatus. This aired during
1982 during the fifth Doctor's run. Before
this the last episode to feature them was
that 1975 episode Revenge of The Cybermen.
The Doctor has to stop the Cybermen from crashing
a giant spaceship into the earth while the
powers of the world try to unite to fight
them off.
There are a few more easter eggs relative
to Series 8 in here. For instance, Adric name
drops Romana and E-Space, which like the pocket
universe is extra dimensional.
Capaldi's Into Darkness comment just makes
me feel like he will be traveling outside
normal space. But there are several places
that could take him. Especially if he's correcting
mistakes of the past.
I'm not expecting Romana to come back or anything.
Number 6 - Pandorica Opens
This was legitimately a team up episode, so
I can't strictly call it a cybermen episode.
But I just love the thought of that cyber
head chomping it's way after Amy and then
Rory splitting it through the door. It's a
lot like the Daleks we saw in Asylum, even
though they look terrible and ancient it doesn't
mean they're harmless.
I always love team up episodes. Usually it's
the Doctor's friends coming to rescue him.
But when all his enemies team up it's even
better.
Number 5 - Silver Nemesis
This is the kind of episode you'd get if you
combined Doctor Who with Merlin and Indiana
Jones. There are three different factions
trying to gain control of one of Rassilon's
artifacts that is used to defend Gallifrey
from attacks. The three factions being the
Cybermen, A Sorceress and a group of Nazis.
This episode was from 1988 which falls between
Temple of Doom and Last Crusade and even if
the writers weren't overtly paying homage
to Indiana Jones, you have to admit that after
those movies anytime you think of Ancient
artifacts and Nazi collectors, you think of
that character.
This was also the 25th Anniversary of Doctor
Who, just giving the Silver in the title a
nice double meaning. The producers tried to
get Prince Edward to appear in it, but the
Royal Family declined.
During the 50th Anniversary the Royal Family
did hold a party to celebrate the occasion.
Number 4 - Nightmare In Silver
There are a lot of mixed feelings about this
episode. Neil Gaiman revealed that originally
it was written as a two part episode, so I
think any complaints about the story people
have were a result of mashing it all into
a single hour.
I always wonder if those promo shots the used
like when it's revealed the Cybermen was the
Turk are written in knowing they'll be used
as promos.
And if you're not familiar, the Turk was a
so called automaton created in the late 18th
century. It was originally designed to be
the world's first robot that would play chess
against you, pretty well too.
Secretly it was a puppet device operated by
a chess master hidden in the bowels of the
machine.
Which is why it was so funny when Warwick
Davis crawled out of the Cybermen Turk.
I also really liked the way they tried to
play with the idea of Mr Clever. The hybrid
organism created when the cyber planner merges
with the Doctor. It got a little silly, but
the gifs of Matt Smith were so hilarious.
The real surprise there was that the Cybermen
found a way to thwart the Doctor's physiological
incompatibilities and assimilate him in mind
if not in body.
Number 3 - Revenge of the Cybermen
This was the first time they were brought
back after long hiatus. They hadn't gotten
a big episode of their own for seven years
prior.
The fourth Doctor learns about a plot where
the Cybermen are infecting people to eliminate
the threat of Gold. One of the Mondas Cybermen
weaknesses was Gold, the metal affected their
organic breathing parts.
This was also the story that aired directly
after Genesis of The Daleks and the episode
that aired right after it was Terror of The
Zygons, two other really important Fourth
Doctor Stories.
Number 2 - Army of Ghosts
The Cybermen in this episode were like the
Hitchhiker's from hell. Just saying they had
nothing to do with the Void Ship Torchwood
was holding. They just used it as an dimensional
bus to jump into N Space.
Unlike Pandorica Opens which came much later.
The Daleks and Cybermen fought against each
other.
These were the Cybus Versions that appeared
earlier during series 2. They were all sucked
into the void but they came back during The
Next Doctor Christmas Special with David Morrisey.
Number 1 - Rise of the Cybermen/Age of Steel
This was the introduction of the Cybermen
in the 2005 reboot with a brand new design.
Like when Star Trek redesigned Klingons for
Next Generation. And as mid-season finale's
go, this was a hell of a two parter. In an
alternate universe, Cybus Industries and John
Lumic created the cybermen as a way to cheat
death, he was terminally ill. And as expected,
the Cybermen went nuts.
Supposedly in that universe about 5 Million
people on earth were assimilated. They broke
into N-Space a few times and iterations of
their design pop up every time we see cybermen.
And just as an alt choice that wasn't a tv
episode a really awesome story is the Big
Finish audio drama Spare Parts. It's like
a Cybermen version of Genesis of The Daleks
starring Peter Davison.
In that story, it's explained that the original
version of the Cybermen from Classic Who were
from a race of people who lived on a planet
that was drifting too close to their sun and
as a measure of last resort they turned themselves
into cybermen.
Gives new meaning to that phrase from the
Trailer, "Life Prevails".
But let me know what your favorite Cybermen
story is, it doesn't have to be an episode.
It can totally be a comic or one of the big
finish stories.
Lots of Cybermen coming in Series 8, get excited.
We don't know what's going to bring them back
yet but I will be doing more weekly bonus
videos until episode 1 airs. That's going
to be on Saturday August 23rd. be sure to
subscribe to get everything.
I'll leave the comic con giveaway open till
the week after.
Right now click here for my breakdown of the
Series 8 Trailer and click here for my top
10 Daleks.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!
ten years ago yesterday was the very first
day of filming on the 2005 Reboot and